good morning it's Tuesday in general I'm
a little reluctant to give advice
because I don't know how to be a person
I mean what the heck is even happening
right now like I'm either inside of a
body that is made of meat or else I am a
body that is made of meat and I'm trying
to live in a world where literally
everything dies except for things that
never lived it's a bit of a weird
situation also what do I know about
being 25 today when I was 25 there were
no iPhones or YouTube or covid really I
think you should be at least slightly
suspicious of anyone who does claim to
be able to advise you on how to live
your life unless those people are like
loved ones who know you intimately which
come to think of it will be my first
piece of advice as with candy be wary of
advice coming from strangers what else I
advise you to floss I know that it's
unpleasant and kind of annoying but I'm
a big fan of flossing not only for
dental health but also because it's a
wondrous Act of Faith flossing is a way
of current you saying I believe there
will be a me in the future who will be
older and more frail than current me
with less healthy teeth and gums and I
floss today not for current me but for
that future me it's a kind of beautiful
thing same with sunscreen by the way I
advise you to write your Memoirs this
needed to be a book or anything it can
be 16 years of weekly YouTube videos or
a 37 hour voice note to yourself or a
series of reviews on a five star scale
that's secretly a memoir but I advise
you to find some way of telling the
story of what it's like to be you now
you may think nobody will read my Memoir
but here you are mistaken the only
meaningful record I have of my great
grandfather's existence is a 17-page
memoir he wrote in the 1930s and I am
extremely grateful for it but also as
somebody who reads a lot of history and
writes a little bit of non-fiction I
cannot tell you how many times I have
wanted to read a memoir that doesn't
exist and many of the people whose
Memoirs I want to read did not consider
themselves noteworthy but the thing is
literally everyone is worthy of note
also here is some advice from Kurt
Vonnegut I urge you to please notice
when you are happy and exclaim or murmur
or think at some point if this isn't
nice I don't know what is I found this
very helpful because otherwise the happy
moments just kind of float past without
acknowledgment and only the hard times
get dwelled upon this is also why I try
to keep a bottle of sparkling grape
juice or champagne on hand at all times
because what if there is good news that
needs to be celebrated like somebody got
a promotion at work or somebody had an
unusually good day let's pop open some
bubbly I just love to commemorate an
occasion commemoration is one of my
favorite things humans do alongside
commiseration a few more pieces of
advice first I advise you to remember
that you are an important presence on
this planet and a wondrous one there are
more viruses in a cup of seawater than
there have ever been humans on this
Earth You are extraordinary and I advise
you to remember that without ever
becoming like too self-satisfied I also
advise you to collaborate because you
don't really do much alone even the
stuff that feels alone like reading for
instance involves lots of other people
not just the author of the book but the
person who chose the font and the people
who taught you to read and so on
collaboration is how we make meaning
together it's how we address the disease
of loneliness together and it's how we
solve our shared problems together
lastly when you can think about where
your attention is going what you're
caring about and attending to and why
because in my opinion anyway human
thought and Consciousness is the single
most valuable resource in the history of
our planet so thank you for being here
with us and thank you for sharing your
attention with us Hank I'll see you on
Friday